[Musik]
endlich
vom idyllischen kreuzlingen und
überwacht die thurgauer seepolizei dem
schweizer teil des 15
und rund um das jahr tag und nach dem
einfach überwachen und schützen den wind
sowie seine besucher zb wasserstoff ist
hier ein sehr politischer und
bundespolizei sagte polizeichefin früher
kurz vor beginn der sommersaison müssen
heute entlang der fahren die
markierungen für die schifffahrt instand
gesetzt werden wo es über die letzte
sich nicht nehmen den kollegen sinnig
zur hand zu gehen
die meisten wm wertung erfolgt an
werbeerinnerung und eine bedauerliche
signalisation erfurt und der technischen
abnahme
[Musik]
der boden weg 60 kilometer lang und 5
kilometer breit
bis zu 254 meter der reihen gibt und md
wasser und hält ihm damit im
ökologischen gleichgewicht ein wenig
braucht mit eindrucksvollen panorama für
anwohner und besucher touristenmagnet
und wichtiger wirtschaft weltweit
bekannt der sie verbindet die schweiz
österreich und deutschland
die drei anderen us staaten teilen sich
die 273 kilometer untereinander auf hier
ist die zusammenarbeit der bodensee
polizei grenzenlos und einzigartig
die schweizer des endlos turbo die
österreichische polizei aus frau albert
und die wasserschutzpolizei aus
deutschland verbindet
länderübergreifende ein gemeinsames ziel
die sicherung des sees und altäre die
noten
heute beobachten alle
wasserschutzpolizisten besorgt das rät
auch über amten auf der schweizer weiter
auf dem untersee bereits eine starke
wind warum eingegangen
die thurgauer seepolizei rückt auch das
mekka der schweiz
sturm aber funktion links kommt derweil
drehmoment darum rät anfang wird wird
immer wichtiger wurden erst seit 2005
von terminen programmliche ihnen die
aufmerksamkeit der politik
[Musik]
dennoch ist die situation 0 für alle
maschinist sechs begeisterter kaiser
fahren
wir hören die wüste gefahren
aber natürlich die wand fahren am
liebsten wäre ja auch drauf nach einem
break er rief mich natürlich schon zum
grillen in ihrem schaffen
nach diesem schock dass man nicht so
flexibel sie mit arbeitsteilige
wirtschaft verwendet gerne machen büro
hoch richter auf wenigsten profitieren
die historiker internet aufgerufen in
kirche und diskutiert
wir haben
auch auf der deutschen seite des bsv
friedrichshafen partie wackernagel die
wasserschutzpolizei in alarmbereitschaft
befindet aber solange die noch so flach
ist es wichtig nach oben schießt bisher
noch
also soll die vorstufe
markus rechts arbeitet seit fünf jahren
bei der wasserschutzpolizei in dieser
zeit ist er zum spezialisten für den
leckeren bodenpflege warten
[Musik]
pro richtung venlo entwickelt nämlich
von hier aus gesehen
und genau dort über dem österreichischen
ufer des seefestes schon bedrohlich
dunkel geworden
auch hier ist die wasserschutzpolizei
auf der rot gelb blinkende lichter am
ufer waren rund um den see
wassersportler vor dem tor stehenden
stören doch immer wieder ignorieren
segen und mutter wird teurer die
warnsignale und bringen damit sich band
und andere in gefahr
die crew des vorarlberger polizeibootes
ist entsprechend achtsamen das
heraufziehende gewitter beunruhigt alle
schätze polizist andreas aus bregenz
kennt die gefahren des leaf und auch
heute verwender designs dienst recht
behalten wird auch sturm bahnfahrt dazu
wir fahren ist für unseren bereich ab
und schaue noch auf irgendwo unterwegs
sind wo eventuell unsere hilfe benötigen
bzw wo wir aufgrund der weisen zweite
mannschaft vielleicht erkennen können
okay wer spricht mit der situation
überfordert dann bleiben wir im
nahbereich wird diese mode das ist ein
problem oder weil man natürlich kraft zu
dem zeitpunkt an einer problem da
springt der bootsbesitzer hatten risse
gefunden und wird in den nächsten hafen
geschleppt
es geht um minuten jetzt ist markus
recht gefragt
ich bin also die master graf die ich
komplett abgesoffen
die einzige möglichkeit die ich sie
haben anker dabei die schieben das paar
meter raus und wir legen vorankommen
werden fällt hält und wenn nicht dann
halt nicht und dann ist man bisweilen an
seite durch
[Musik]
auch auf der österreichischen seite ist
mit der ruhe vorbei vorträge entweder
ein hobby sich vermehren
wir werden ja wir waren mal ein
mai dauert vier tage
im trainingslager mit wifi
ihr name wie reagieren
ein kilometer
der drei motive
freunde des vermissten hat mal
angeschlagen können aber nur vage
angaben machen
andrea vor ort informiert die
einsatzzentrale und ruft weitere
rettungskräfte zu hilfe was richtung
regeln wir schauen auch diese person ich
mich laut unterwegs rein vom
bodenständigen cfl seenotfall regensburg
angeblich auch rote deutschland ab
plötzlich meldet sich ein gegner der das
coni wird gesichtet
wann genau wir haben ok ich glaube wir
treten hier der polizei im moment warten
wir haben sich kontakte zu den schlauch
post gerade in suchen irgendwann das
regelbuch muster dahinter gelbe
segelbooten und er bei dem kläger aber
noch der vermisste im schlauchboot
bleibt verschreien leitwort manko ist
auch in meinen augen ist die situation
noch nicht unter kontrolle
wie weit kommen wir hier ein mit seinem
20 aber nur 50 metern 18
und dann ist los aber dann kam es auch
nicht dass web lange nicht machen
das problem ist dass wenn wir jetzt hier
richtig wählen ziegen und richtig
stunden sondern droht da zumindest mal
eine gewässerverunreinigung durch die
betriebsstoffe dienen dem boot sind und
natürlich der totalschaden von von dem
boot was jetzt zu suchen müssen den
anker zu setzen da draußen das halt
vielleicht dass familien die mauer
das boot muss gewonnen werden
die sturmfront campina
in österreich wurde das vermisste
schlauchboot noch immer nicht berichtet
[Musik]
dann endlich entdeckt josef joffe in der
kino in duisburg haben
[Applaus]
mithalten
nicht ohne strom
ok
bitte kollege kommt dann finden wir
werfen die deutschen kollegen ein auge
auf die sportkegler
machen routine maneuver rettungsfall
jens ludwig will auf nummer sicher gehen
mittlerweile windstärke 8 was einer
geschwindigkeit von 60 bis 70
stundenkilometern entspricht
[Musik]
er hat dabei kräfte markt
wir haben dafür aus morgen frau ganz
gemütlich
vielleicht noch ein bisschen regen und
dann vom dorp
zum glück haben sich mittlerweile alle
wassersportler in sicherheit gebracht
doch ein polizeiboot muss bei sturm
immer auf den 7
christoph mandalka leiter der
wasserschutzpolizei in friedrichshafen
überwacht von der zentrale aus die
rettungseinsätze
er kennt wie kein anderer die gefahren
seine friedens bodensee hat natürlich
meteorologisch gesehen seine tücken
das heißt viele urlauber die hier den
sommer verbringen am bodensee unsere
schätzen diesen umstand auch ein schöner
samstag beginnen am vormittag kann am
nachmittag ganz schnell zur katastrophe
führen
in langen atem und markus brecht immer
noch gegen eine rollende
wasserverschmutzung endlich liegt das
boot gestützte menschen zum glück weiter
vorne was bei diesen wellen dann
vermutlich lanxess mit und hätte großen
schaden angerichtet
für markus precht ist der einsatz damit
erledigt die feuerwehr wird das
motorboot mit einem kran aus dem wasser
heben
[Musik]
auf dem österreichischen bowtell andreas
ab jetzt wissen wie ihn war wurden fünf
gegangen
auch
mario
in akt
lügen
ak
akw
der applaus
mag so
[Musik]
spiegel herr b
glauben abspeckte frischen ananas 23
herstellen
leider nein
je genauer alkoholmenge lässt sich wohl
nicht mehr ermitteln und auch was die
personalien betrifft war die befragung
nicht gerade ergiebig nachfrage bei den
deutschen kollegen
die frage zur melderegister vorname
andrea frey weise was das kann alles
mögliche sein erst relativ alkoholisiert
aber vielleicht hat junge mit joker
suchen was man vor nicht in aktuell
wenig
danke
an land wartet bereits sein kollege der
weg zum den durstigen fischer kümmern
doch wissen hier kunstbetriebs
aber auch wofür
die folge ist dass die freunde des
mannes wurden informiert und werden ihn
gleich nach hause bringen
oder sich einfach keine spielwiese
gewässer wo sind die dicken haut klar
der weg der ruf zerstören
dann kann schneller moers basiere und
manche leute wirklich ein sturm kummer
sind diese ängste sturm
das buch das aus richtung vollständige
das cliq verantwortung erneut diskutiert
einer von 450 menschen die jährlich auf
dem boden werden neue einsatz erst recht
der polizei dort 21
zwei wochen einen kleinen ohne motor
noch ist die einsatzlage sehr
unübersichtlich
die sich dem schreiben hat die schule
ja
keine ahnung
ein fährschiff hat eine der vermissten
person aufgenommen die anderen steine
verleihen land geschafft haben aber die
tätigkeit der kollegen auf dem see
sicher wieder eine permanente
herausforderung weil der see hat jeden
tag ein anderes gesicht
und da kann man keinen fall mit dem
anderen vergleichen weil man ständig an
das natürlich auch die gräben die
wettersituation auch reagieren muss doch
band sogar kurze zeit für privates
die polizisten alltag ist tief in der
nacht wird markus brecht heimkommen für
deine familie
[Musik]
sonntagmorgen in münsterlingen auf der
schweizer seite des bodensees
wie politisch brunos nieder kommt als
taucher zum einsatz in der mysteriöse
fall
anwohner haben das herrenlose motorboot
bestimmen beweissicherung unter wasser
dieses motorrad hierher gekommen ist
fest steht wenn benzin und motors laufen
haben hier ein problem
[Musik]
kontrolle des fahrrad den halt nicht
erreicht kuriosen ist nur das letzte
nacht ein bruch in der region um
markdorf mit dem control sieht
beobachtet wird flüchtete stellt das als
ganz klares delikte rindern
noch die weiteren ermittlungen müssen
nun von den kollegen an land übernommen
werden
der rein dann beiträgen nicht gerade ein
typischer liegeplatz verbot offenbare
der skipper in der nacht die
orientierung verloren
die vor al gaddafi polizei ermittelt
unfallflucht obwohl alkohol im spiel
eine beamtin der spurensicherung den
tatort untersuchen
fingerabdrücke und dna spuren
sicherstellen passierte lag sie um kurz
nach fünf uhr morgens und scheinbar laut
aussage vom steuermann wechselten wir
wissen mit genau erfahren ist schlimm
verletzt
und er macht der raumluft lässt gewisse
rückschlüsse zu aber wir werden nichts
behauptete vor
unfallflucht ist auch auf dem wasser
kein kavaliersdelikt
die polizei muss nun ermitteln wie der
schiffsführer einem vier meter hohen
damm übersehen konnte und warum er nach
dem unfall abgetaucht ist
sollten sich mehr personen auf dem boot
befunden haben das wissen auch nicht
wann sich der zulassungsbesitzer noch
nicht meldet oder melden will könnte sie
dass man den irgendjemand an gibt eben
fahrer überhaupt nicht fahren ist und
dass man denn anhand der dna spuren
beweisen können wer tatsächlich frauen
mit dem gesicherten dna-spuren die sache
den sachschaden schätzten die polizisten
auf gut 20.000 euro in den folgenden
tagen zeigt sich der see weiterhin von
seiner schönsten seite und es wird immer
heißer die thermometer in die höhe
geschossen
die polizistin koller prüft die
wasserwerte rekordverdächtig
die militärs gezeigt
natürlichkeit
mehr
ex-polizist eberli ist mit an bord und
ein boot mit wasserski vorhand gerät ins
visier der polizist wie rucola
beobachtet die hobby kapitäne zunächst
auf eine war entfernung und seine
vermutung besteht endlich
mehrmals mussten die wassersportler
diesen geltende free rechnung zeigt für
eine besserung
hallo
roadcross
ein
euro
[Musik]
konstanz ein dramatischer anruf setzt
dem führungs und lagezentrum der polizei
die rettungskette in bewegung
die wasserschutzpolizei verständigen wie
steht s broker und unsere teams ließ
vorfall verständigt sofort machen des
polizeioberkommissar thomas dahmen und
polizeihauptmeister jens ludewig vom
hafen in langenargen aus auf dem gebiet
schon nach wenigen minuten erreichen
laut polizei 120 stimmen verloren
jetzt muss endlich glücken reagieren und
untergegangen und rückseite
der rettungshubschrauber mit dem notarzt
daten dramatische eingeführten er den
schwimmer gewichtung von street
der mann wird als krieg los
dort beginnt in berlin jens ludewig
attraktion
das jeden tag an verspricht
und meine fraktion den einsatz von
kehrtwende und versucht alles was
möglich ist und dann
bitte alle ausgesteckt auf den magen und
trübe stimmung wie können die polizisten
dieser mentalen belastung standhalten
verarbeitung dieser unfälle sind
natürlich zunächst einmal in der
anfangsphase immer belastend das kann an
keinem kollegen kann es fotos
vorbeigehen
allerdings hat man natürlich auch im
lauf der jahre durch die eigene
erfahrungen die man gemacht hat sich
eine relativ sage ich mal dicke fell
angeeignet muss man das endlich auch um
mit diesem wechsel natürlich
dementsprechend auch umgehen zu können
ein versöhnlicher verarbeiten zu können
der 68-jährige mann ertrank vermutlich
aufgrund eines kreislaufversagen
so sagt die rekordhitze im sommer 2015
auch für einen traurigen rekord 19
badetoten der klagt der bodensee in
diesem jahr
es ist ein schöner sonntag nachmittag
mit viel verkehr auf dem rhein zwischen
ober und unter sich
[Musik]
der inhalt zeitpunkt der
polizeikontrollen
wir sind geschwindigkeitskontrollen kann
die beobachtung ist genau gleich wie auf
der straße
nein ich habe ein kollege der unterricht
erhält die ahnen macht vorhalt und wenn
haben sie gleich zu bezahlen oder mit
einzahlungsschein von 313
15 30 16 16 1550 aber ich muss jetzt
aufgebaut keiner momente rohstoff
angriff
b
[Musik]
wo es über die dienste der thurgauer
seepolizei übernimmt
[Musik]
also nach und kauft alle die mit 14 sagt
alle aufzuzählen die strömung
unterschätzt
mit drei tollen verbleiben noch eine
überschreitung wird das höre dann breite
30 fahren können 30 fragen
pilz räumen aufklären
bananen retten das sind die
hauptaufgaben der seepolizei
[Musik]
im regen entwickelt sich inzwischen ein
polemisches schauspiel im schatten der
festspielbühne ein fischer und
bootsvermieter kreuzen die klingen
nicht zum ersten mal die position und
seine kollegen kennen der schon gibt sie
immer wieder schwierigkeiten und zwar
weil dieser beruf fischer seine netze in
der art flachwasser aus bringt wo die
vollständig einfach mit der schraube
oder mit dem team vom boot hängen
bleiben
oder ein
helga fischer und guten ideen irgend
sich nicht
jetzt ist viel fingerspitzengefühl
gefragt
der entwickelt
wir möchten die haben zu ende gedacht
richtig macht immerhin unfallbericht
polizei am bodensee zeigen denn vivi moo
weil wenn glücklichsten okay die teils
durch was sie will die fraktion in
leverkusen muss funktionieren
mit lohnverzicht auf den astra und ernst
es die gäste hatten nur gegen
amtshandlungen durchführt höheren the
world hat wer kontrolliert und aroma
freiwillig gemischte gefühle zeigt
öffentliche empörung beantragt der
heldin dort der unfallaufnahme und
nächsten schimpfen sie können gar nichts
dafür dass der heute zuständig für die
misere für die mission der polizei also
gut auch wenn es solche lager bringen
der anfeindungen andreas hauptplatz
gelangen über den dingen stehen
sachlich bleiben mitunter auf durchzug
schalten deutlich friedlicher geht es
auf der schweizer seite zu aber dann ein
notruf
100 jahren
dw
ans land
porsche plant
b
das genau spare dadurch dem körper oder
weg führt oft mit lustig
nun gespannt
das sparbuch fasziniert obwohl jetzt
heißt es 30 minuten vollgas geben bis
der unfallstelle
internationale
auch das deutsche polizei gut 21 ist
bereits unterwegs zum vermuteten absturz
also zwei dauerhaft luftfahrt ist
zugewanderter april vorstellt hat bei
dem mangelnden ballonfahrt prost ducati
januar durchgefallen
muttertag direkt an dingen die man auf
dem motorrad unterwegs mit ran
das deutsche boot erwartet weitere
dienste nahezu ganz nacht verfahren die
schweizer haben die konstant ok fehler
auf unserer seite
dass sie alle versprechen mehr ab ganz
abbrechen
also das ist ein schlechtes über schweiz
die türkei sind unsere energie ich von
haus unterwegs und die konstanzer es
schaffen wir jetzt so können abbrechen
der zwang der bund hat die unfallstelle
gereist
das sind kosten werden die regierungen
allein wegen eines abgestürzten ballon
der einsatz war für die polizisten ein
einsatz wie jeder andere
[Musik]
die österreichische polizei auf
kontrollfahrt andreas held heute selbst
steuernde hand
immer im fokus
motorboote und ihre schiffsführer ein
kleines boot mit annan fällt auf
manfred höfler bittet zum gespräch mit
land kontrolliere spitze vorne hinter
facebook nur für akute überbietet
zulassungsschein hier und schäfer bei
den verfolgern arbeit dabei noch alle
die note größte macht die mädchen müssen
fans dabei hat sie für jedes kind eine
kinderversion investieren und sie für
die anderen drei kinder basteln die
kinder bist du dabei
radio.de
wie praktisch
und werk hört für die donauwörther die
hilfe europas und werte also eigentlich
kaum mehr kredit jeder weiß hier hinter
die kleine kameras überquerte als eine
bei 1 3110 der messe felder funktioniert
schneider
da ist woher körper funktioniert
irgendwie ein feuerlöscher bin aber
sicher dass er nicht richtig vorgeführt
ist
theoretisch
er darf maximal zwei jahre vorgeführt
sein logo erst ab 2011 also der gewonnen
dafür demminer ding hier rettungs
wurfgerät mit dem kleinen schweine daran
dies will eine bestimmte länge
damit wiesen zugreifen können wir daher
okay größte problem war für die also
erst mal grund für die anhaltend tiefen
hinter dem renault markieren und
schnäbel vorne vorgänger um mit der
serie hat uns wir müssen weil sie welche
cink mit dem ring ansonsten mit dem
thema gestoßen wären sie sind zwar
grundsätzlich der rechts kommende und
während dem vorgang aber das kann
natürlich eigentlich zivile ganze gerät
das gilt wir an was wir genau und der
duft den sie eigentlich nur 300 meter
zone kubanische genäht fahrer also ddr
verboten
das wären rund 1.20 anträge notfällen zu
erwachsenen schwimmweste eine kinder
schwimmweste ein richtiger feuerlöscher
360 grad nicht passt und was nur
dramatisch ist sie viel zu viele
personen an bord
ihr wollt ist zugelassen für vier
personen das wort drei kinder unter
einer bestimmten alter zähler 2
erwachsene und dann sind sie halt schon
komplett sondern hält die tiere wachsen
ist ein kind eigentlich zu viel
sie waren sind was jetzt mit dem boot
zurückgenommen ganz einfach der tag
müssen jetzt einfach attraktiv und alles
weitere wie wir das ganze mal an die
bezirkshauptmannschaften bregenz
berichten muss und sie kriegen hat über
die schweizer behörden hatten rief zu
stellen betreffen da klingt einfach
straub und sieht uns zahlen
horst aber das mit den zahlen lägen sie
muss natürlich das boot wieder auf
vordermann bringen fasste staatsbürger
hat aber der spitze hauptwort und daran
müssen wir jetzt an die politik
darum wird der roadie nicht strafzahlung
muss genommen
einige tage später im revier der
schweizer die polizei herrscht
hochbetrieb
an clubheim gummiboote und community
schlaflosigkeit nicht wissen
schifffahrtszeichen genannt die grünen
tieferes und weiß flachere skelette
seien die polizisten können gar nicht an
bord
vergleiche mit dreck war der
wasserschutzpolizeien kunst an
innendienst und vom geliebte
schreibarbeit
[Musik]
ein notruf er die nie schlesiger und
wenn kollegen tobias anhänger am wehr
ein ganz in der nähe der wache ist ein
junges mädchen kollabiert genaueres
wissen die was das cisco noch nicht
zunächst geht es darum in ort des
geschehens welt zu finden
[Musik]
haben sie angehoben
angerufen herunter kann
das muss es mit als ausgebildeter
rettungssanitäter missliebiger bei einem
kreislaufkollaps kann es um leben und
tod gehen würde wusste funktion jetzt
gerade ist sie einfach nur aus
okay das ganze eben ein schiffsunfall
deswegen von wasserschutzpolizei lang
war bewusstlos
also nur okay gut dann eben hat eben
gucken wenn sie eine zeit lang
bewusstlos war ohne atmung wegen um
schäden gleich
[Musik]
45 kilometer entfernt auf dem hochrhein
die thurgauer seepolizei ssten wird noch
immer damit beschäftigt den stadtverkehr
zu reden
dieser anruf für den weiteren
tagesablauf völlig auf den kopf stellen
jahren polizist
für ihn ist klar eine vermisste person
hat höchste priorität
jetzt sind alle verfügbaren kräfte
gefragt
er muss von hand ins auto umsteigen die
entfernung ist zu groß
während der fahrt steht in ständigem
kontakt mit der einsatzleitung
standard
[Musik]
nach etwa 60 kilometern im ort des
geschehens in konstanz gemacht ist
derweil weiter um die kleine vanessa
jahre alt das machen wir bräuchten ein
arm von dir am besten den linken arm
kopf haben die polsterschlacht
vanessa muss sofort für weitere
untersuchungen ins krankenhaus gebracht
werden
verena becker ist der fall damit
abgeschlossen
[Musik]
kleine war sehr aufgebracht wollten nur
noch heim
mir war kalt obwohl sie zugedeckt worden
plattform schattenarmee trotzdem draußen
30 grad also sieht schon die kleinen
kinder sagen was wir haben also
in der schweiz spitzen wird die
ereignisse zu das belastet noch immer
vermisst
foto aus allen richtungen stoßen dazu
auch ein kino friedrichshafen die
deutschen wasserschutzpolizei 15 jetzt
und der schweiz zu kommen
[Musik]
die totale dekolleté drei gleitet ihn
eingefahren
keine karten von bord gefallen klein
wenig bekannt wird ist somit vom tisch
wir müssen genau in der suchkette
kenntnis
wir suchen jetzt richtung ost erfahrung
mit 160 grad 50 meter abstand ganz
wichtigkeit von einer stunde eine auf
die verfügbaren kräfte sind im einsatz
18 boote suchen mittlerweile sind sie
nach den vermissten schwimmer ab
und deshalb sucht die einsatzleitung
sagte spendet viel hoffnung den
vermissten noch lebend zu bergen und ihr
kaum noch jemand nachmachen
drei kinder deren vater vermutlich
ertrunken ist eine besprechung war der
betrieb der märkte massiv die user etwas
ganz fertig sind erste mal begangen wird
und ihr habt ein geteiltes echo frau
überrascht vom x6 im bad kreuznach nehme
es ernst
der bootsführer rettungsring das ganze
so schnell gegangen waren
man probiere allerdings kritisch
die vermisste person konnte nicht
gefunden werden als vermischt gold
inhalt durch leistung der winter ag an
dieser stelle der familienvater
untergegangen
der steirische beschränken
die stadträtin
[Musik]
natürlich befinden was in dem sie und
offenbar schon heute besser verdienen
und wenn man kein familie war es gar
nicht so einfach ein problem mit der ich
finde dieser kritischen phase zugang die
polizei beschäftigen
einsatz für die kampfmittel taucher der
deutschen wasserschutzpolizei körper
können auch nach jahrzehnten dem wasser
noch explodieren gefahren eher selten
nachrichten
immer wieder müssen diese
hinterlassenschaften des krieges
geworden wären
für die gegenstände liegen circa 70
jahre aber im bereich dem russischen
sehr beliebtes gebiet zum schwimmen
krawatte gebiet wegen der regel personen
den dort zum schwimmen und warten wurden
von dem her ist es nicht ganz
ungefährlich die kinder auch erwachsene
des deutschen spielen damit um briefing
auf dem weg zum einen lernen
und deswegen ist es natürlich dass
irgendwas anlangt das was ganz anders
denkt und das doch vielleicht denn der
verein findet und mit einem entsprechend
stärker verletzt aber im frankfurter zoo
den wald locken
ein aufmerksamer keine party gehalten
schon mich einfach von blindgängern
gewarnt ja ich find's einfach unheimlich
muss fährt sozusagen hier ein sonar
urlaubsgegend mit seinem kanu viele
leute wissen gar nicht dass hier
kriegshandlungen stattgefunden haben
das sieht jetzt so idyllisch aus und es
war einfach so eine tolle gegend und da
werden sicher viele erstaunt dass wir so
etwas in wallung
das vermutete fundort ist intensiviert
wir haben die kammern fündig zu werden
kreuzlingen am tag nach der erfolglosen
suche nach dem vermissten china noch
immer gibt es keine neuen erkenntnisse
in den tragischen fall bonus nieder
schaltet sich in die ermittlungen ein
morgen wurden die roma sind immer noch
unklar
das war krieg der sterne küche sowie für
personen mit noka der kfz betrieb kein
modell notruf ausgelöst internationale
und treiber für flug und sport zurück
machen allenfalls der dritte bereich
pflichten haben ja wenn ich was mache
mich da einfach nochmals leicht gehabt
wie dem thema mit ehefrau möglichst mit
dem av wichtig dass wir die person finde
dass das ein abschluss findet
für mich die noch im see wo irgendwo sie
machen einfach nicht funktionierende
führer räumt aber auch ein ungefährer
punkt ungefähr die koordinaten und das
dorf wichtig dass man nun aber sucht
unter angehörigen schuldig dass man
alles mögliche zu vier personen finden
[Musik]
im uferbereich bei friedrichshafen wird
nach gefährlichem blindgängern getaucht
noch konnte keine der bomben geboren
einsatzleiter oberstenfeld die
koordination der suche gericht
unterdessen schlecht jetzt geht die
nerven zu behalten
den siegpunkt waterfront aufzug ich
halte ihn fest und praktischen halbkreis
jetzt kommt der reisebereich vorliegen
wie alle kommunen muss kurz hoch kommen
vom behälter übernehmen
nach mehreren stunden intensiver suche
endlich der erste anflug eine fachfirma
mitgebracht
nur müssen die billigflieger darauf
achten dass der sprengstoff auf keinen
fall mit sauerstoff in berührung kommen
auch nach 60 jahren in drei meter tiefe
sind die banken noch immer
brandgefährlich und mitverfasser in
spezialbehältern lustig verpackt die 15
kilo schweren sprengstoff körper müssen
nun schnellstmöglich unschädlich gemacht
werden
das ist der job mit
kampfmittelbeseitiger
wie bleibt erstmal helfer hier drin und
mir bringen
nach stuttgart ins lager rang da kommt
den großen verbrennungsofen runde
gewonnen
bei den folgenden tauchgängen bergen die
täter zwei weitere phosphorbomben und
drei dieser stadt brandbomben der
einsatzleiter zufrieden wegen der sehr
viele kampfmittel wurden wir auch
größere gruppen anhand der luftbilder
bewertung kamera sagen
vieles liegt und warf eigentlich wird
fällt leben die alles geboten werden
romanshorn
seit mehreren tagen durch die schweizer
seepolizei einen ertrunken
jetzt kommt bewegung in den fall die
auswertung von soonahe bildern hat
eindeutige hinweise gebracht
[Musik]
wirken
die idee
das beliebte aufgrund von signal vom
bild vermutet er dass man erfolgreich
wäre natürlich super dass vor allem für
die angehörigen nach wie vor dem
ungewissen sind war ich mit diesem
familienmitglied und der werden
eine unterwasserkamera will gewissen
effekt auf den wiesen rückt verzockt
genau angesteuert
[Musik]
georg marti von der armee ist im
schweizerischen bundesamt für rüstung
ist spezialist für solche einsätze
momente wie stecker
doch eine pumpe fordern
[Musik]
prof
fehlanzeige es sind nur pflanzen
wie der kontoeröffnung auf
ja wer ich auf phuket und ihrer liebe
sagen
[Musik]
ramelow brunos nieder gibt nicht auf er
versucht alle von den vermissten zu
finden stunden verdienen hitze rasch
leerstand schöne roben
hannover
er nicht darum hat sich breit
stundenlang haben sie den boden
abgesucht nicht gefunden
übung abbruch
wer nur möglich gemacht
einige marken im bereich von
realistischer nicht von hannover und
druckt richter von der vermietung 60
menschen liegen auf dem grund des sees
des suchgebietes trotz modernster
technischer ausrüstung einfach zu groß
an diesem tag ist ein weiterer
ungeklärte fall entzogen und durch
schickte drei im moment studieren
oranien circuit altmeister daran falsch
interpretiert vorfall aber mit dem
beschluss ein peters das ist realität
19 tote alleine im rekordsommer 2015
wie gefährlich
[Musik]
die wasserschutzpolizei konstanz
unterwegs preise wenig ruhiger und sein
kollege tobias armleder neuen eine
segelregatta begleiten als glücklich am
notruf
nico hat müssen die polizisten
blitzschnell von der landschaft in den
alarm modus umschalten
hierunter signal durch die ganzen
unternehmen jetzt ehrlich da keine
rücksicht
angehoben
natürlich höllisch aufpassen wir sind
natürlich nicht so schnell in der
reaktion weg und ich mach deine zwei
paare katar manöver kaputt meine
heckwelle aber ich kein verändern also
mir im moment egal welches um die kinder
mehr
tatsächlich glück sind die kollegen der
lebensrettung vernetzung von daten
während angebot können sie nie werden
absolute flachwasserbereich kann ihren
große sich jeden fall mehr tiefgang vom
1 meter 40 und mir haben wir unterm kiel
noch ein meter 20
eindeutig
die meldung kam reid auf dem flug wurden
kontrolliert
ja ich will dich fertig
zumal unkontrolliert merkmal wenn kein
wind oder wasser weise und wind bekommt
wohl behalten
die kinder sind gerettet dlrg bringt sie
jetzt im yachthafen zu ihre eltern und
überstellte zum 6
doch zu klein dafür aber sie war noch
relativ vom land weg also sich besser
wenn sie diese spielchen im schwimmbad
machen
unter aufsicht wie hier am bodensee der
rohstoff durchzuatmen
[Musik]
anfang august noch immer herrscht
tropisches
die bodenseeregion steuer das
alljährliche heimat zu dass sich nachts
von konstanz und kreuzlingen
die gäste bringen sich schon tagsüber
einstimmung für das nächtliche feuerwerk
[Musik]
ein
für die wasserschutzpolizei
erfahrungsgemäß ein streng vor dem ende
polit rang 24 ist unser weg von
einsatzort im konstanzer trichter
die maßnahme wurde von hier koordiniert
wird es hier keine filme die diebe welt
den offenbar kommen diensten michael
hubert trinken wirklich um die
gesundheit der besucher
[Musik]
die skipper auf dem weg liefen die
gebotenen attraktionen und verdienten
sich schon mal aber hier auch dieser
abend nach dem feuerwerk zehn kilometer
beschränkung sie zum tee zu entwarnen
runter aber erst ein
[Musik]
auch beim arbeiten die position kräfte
aus der schweiz und sein
partnerschaftlich zusammen
die gäste am ufer sichern sich bereits
die besten plätze feuerwehr
[Musik]
zur gleichen zeit in bremen andreas raab
und seine crew sind auf dem weg sein
[Musik]
volle kraft voraus zum einsatz
in der bühne bringen
die nächste kreislaufkollaps erlitten
haben wahrscheinlich prinzipiell ein
rettungseinsatz so die leute und die
wachsen rät wenn ich zuständig wir schau
doch mal unterstützen können
[Musik]
am ufer wird bereits andere
rettungskräfte mainland andreas rodde
sich trotzdem persönlich einen eindruck
über die lage verschaffen
er trifft auf den lebensgefährten der
kuratierten frau der in den
unfallhergang schilderte bereich vertrag
mündung und plötzlich in begleitung von
lebenspartner lebensgefährten und
plötzlich regungslos die waffe kläger
die hatte selber unter unterstützung von
zwei jugendlichen wieder vorbildlich
reanimation durchführten daher braucht
und jetzt ist es an die frau dem
rettungsfahrzeug und so wirtschaftlich
momentan gelang ihnen andreas rach
möchte den dritten helfern für ihren
einsatz dann doch die jungen männer sind
bereits wieder auf den wiesen
aufgefahren
kollege vor eine wand stellen das aber
hier der ford fahrer und beifahrer ein
kurzer bericht
ok
von iris couragierten eingreifen haben
die männer ein menschenleben gerettet
im konstanzer den startet gigantischen
feuerwerk die anspannung aber chef
politisch bleibt wie immer höflich
klingt nach geld und dow war
auch in isny teams gegen die unvernunft
des kurses wenn er kein nicht dabei habe
dann mit der frist an machen ansonsten
direkt und verfahren sieht man nicht
alle heute nicht angekommen gleich sehr
viel vorgang stück herunter
heute haben mit grant
die stuttgarter in den recht aber das
sind nur kurz fällt auf den falschen
seite oder auch das weiße seite
ein kurzes grünes licht zum stand des
trierer beginnen mit dem feuerwerk in
der schweiz wird auch circa zwölf
minuten dann weitergeführt werber mit
dem feuerwerk auf deutscher seite
[Musik]
gegründet
letzte woche war ich schon so
rheinbrücke
da konnten einfach sperren da mich die
leute dran halten
es geht los
positiv und wir haben noch einen tag den
zweiten brach sein motto nicht schlecht
ist man abwechslung zum arbeitsalltag
aber mussten wir für jeden abend haben
sich zunächst wieder ein ganzes jahr
fertig
[Musik]
sogar in ihrer freizeit bietet die
frauen und männer der polizei immer
wieder ans wasser juli geht die liebe zu
seinem revier über das rein berufliche
hinaus ihre tänze ausflugsschiffe
erwarten wir mit dem rad verbandes
reiner sich vom vor den autofahrer mit
dem segler auf und da ich jetzt
normalerweise täglich tausende menschen
wie sie den appell dfb und fünf gramm
frische die aufregung war eine ganz
lange linien wir berichten natürlich
luftfahrt und einzigartiger
arbeitsplätze sich polizist nach drei
nationen
[Musik]